un train sillonne les régions oubliées
d'Afrique du Sud à son bord aucun
voyageur mais 15 médecins et infirmière
les Sud-Africains l'ont appelé féopppa
un mélange de langues Soto et Tsana pour
dire bonne
santé 10 ans après les débuts de la
démocratie le phéoppppa reste l'unique
chance d'être soigné pour les
populations les plus démunies cette
année sa route le conduit à Upington une
ville de 72000 habitants dans le
nord-ouest du
pays malgré la fin de l'aapide les
communautés blanches noires et métisses
y vivent toujours
[Musique]
cloisonné dans l'école métisse de
Morning Glory les enfants reçoivent
souvent leur seul repas de la journée le
jour où le phéopépa arrive on compte sur
eux pour aller porter la Bonne
Nouvelle les
enfants j'aimerais que vous distribuiez
ce prospectus à vos parents il explique
tout sur le fa ce train qui arrive chez
nous
àingt il y aura des médecins il y aura
des dentistes il y aura des
psychologues est-ce que les gens qui ont
le cancer peuvent aller au train oui
bien sûr et les gens qui ont le sida
est-ce qu'ils peuvent y aller oui les
gens qui ont le sida peuvent y aller
parce qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent
leur donner des
conseils tout le monde peut se rendre au
train et être soigné pour vraiment pas
cher Raymon explique-moi pourquoi tu
veux aller au
train je l'ai dit hier à mon
frère je veux aller au train pour mes
yeux et mon frère m'a dit que lui il
irait pour ses
dents Ron a 14 ans il a déjà 2 ans de
retard à l'école parce qu'il ne voit pas
[Musique]
bien
les 16 wagons du train viennent
d'arriver du personnel local s'empresse
d'installer les salles
[Musique]
d'attente un peu plus loin les premiers
soignants montent à bord et découvrent
leur chambre africanire pour la plupart
ils ont entre 20 et 26 ans débarquer des
grandes universités de Johannesbourg
Prétoria ou d'urbane ces futurs
opticiens dentistes ou infirmières sont
bénévoles ils vont vivre à bord du train
pendant 2
semaines die oorlog op my neered ga die
sakkie Inkom
nieourour
Lilian Singo a fu la part pour suivre
ses études d'infirmière et de
psychologie à Londres à l'heure de la
démocratie elle décide de revenir pour
prendre les commandes du
phéopa ce train n'est pas là simplement
pour guérir des
maladies ce train est aussi là pour
soulager mentalement et
psychologiquement ces gens et vous savez
que ces personnes que vous devez servir
ont besoin de ça
donc nous vous soutiendrons mais il
faudra vous jeter à l'eau et à vous de
ne pas
couler 6h30 par un matin
d'hiver vous gagnez vous gagnez pelppa
debout debout toute l'équipe du pelppa
c'est un matin exceptionnel et beaucoup
de Sud-Africains comptent sur vous pour
les aider alors motivez-vous soyez
thousiaste
réveillez-vous debout
debout G
vous savez ce sont des jeunes ils ont
besoin de se reposer ce n'est pas facile
pour eux de sortir du
lit alors il faut que je les encourage
que je les
motive et que je le rappelle le
mission ils savent ce qu'il doivent
faire mais ce n'est pas toujours
facile plus de 200 patients vont arriver
dans la journée ils ont souvent marché
des kilomètres ou payé un taxi Bruce
pour venir parmi les premiers Raymond
qui s'est rasé les cheveux pour
l'occasion et son frère Robert qui a
payé le
bus la gare d'ppington n'a jamais été
aussi pleine à l'accueil on organise les
files
d'attente en gros les gens arrivent et
vont voir le monsieur de la sécurité
là-bas c'est à lui qu'il disent qui ils
veulent voir il leur donne un ticket
soit pour les dents les yeux ou pour une
consultation générale tout le monde
passe par ici et dès qu'ils ont plus de
14 ans on prend leur tension et on
vérifie leur
diabète très bien lui il peut aller
là-bas cette femme aussi cette femme là
aussi et les deux autres aussi pour les
[Applaudissements]
yeux m à la foule elle oriente les
patientsux qui sont perdus n réussi de
[Musique]
tick c'est ici pour se faire tester les
yeux et avoir des lunettes oui mais vous
devez d'abord aller là où il y a le
panneau blanc vous remplissez les
formulaires et vous revenez nous voir
ok monsieur on nous a dit de venir ici
pour les yeux et pour les
dents clinique est pleine on peut
seulement vous aider pour les
yeux toi c'est pour tes yeux très bien
ass-toi làon a de la chance il obtient
le ticket numéro 108 dans la liste
d'attente mais pour Robert c'est déjà
trop
tard ici les consultations sont grates
pour médament pour une dent on paye
moins d'un € et une paire de lunettes ne
coûte que 6
€ un vagon plus loin les patients sont
déjà trop nombreux tous veulent voir le
dentiste le docteur Maine Kritzinger le
médecin le plus convoité du train cette
ancienne étudiante avait commencé à bord
du féopa en tant que stagiaire
aujourd'hui employée permanente elle a
15 étudiants sous sa
[Musique]
responsabilité je vais commencer à
anesthésier pas mal de
patients pour qu'on avance plus
vite sinon on va terminer à 9h ce
soir j' bien mais sans plus en fait j'ai
peur 17 ans première visite chez le
dentiste pour elle veut se faire enlever
de
dents non il faut pas avoir peur
suis-moi
tu peux t'asseoir
ici ok je vais commencer à tirer sur ta
d si ça te fait mal tu me dones un coup
de
pied Bradley est étudiant à préoria
l'année prochaine il sera diplômé pour
l'heure il a besoin d'aide et c'est
Maine une fois de plus qui est
sollicité
docteur excusez-moi de vous déranger
j'ai une d très Carrié je n'arrive pas à
l'enlever ils ne savent pas comment
prendre soin de leurs dents parce qu'il
personne pour le
expliquer onag expérience enisant ça
on voit que paents par semaine pour des
extractions de et aujourd'hui j'en ai
fait
20 tu es
contente dans certains cas Lilian doit
intervenir pour trouver une dernière
place
excuse-moi j'ai une grande faveur une
très grande faveur à te demander
Maine n pas impatient comme les autre
cette femme est dans un fauteuil s'il te
plaît Maine est-ce que tu peux encore
t'en occuper
merci il faut toujours que je
négocieoup vu un médecin de leur vie
pendant plus de 40 ans d'appartide on
leur a refusé l'accès au soins et
aujourd'hui les listes d'attente de
l'hôpital public sont trop longue le
coût d'une consultation est de 100
rendes l'équivalent de 15 € trop cher et
les médicaments sont trop
rares j'aimerais qu'il y ait encore plus
de monde qui puisse profiter du train
pour moi ce n'est jamais assez bien sûr
il y a une limite à ce que l'on peut
faire mais il y a toujours du monde qui
attend et la vérité c'est qu'
la journée entière mais peu importeingt
il n'y a pas d'opticien qui puisse
l'aiderpement de deête il ne voit pas
très bien de loin non
plus on va juste regarder sil a besoin
de lunett c'est ça le
problme
est-ce que c'est mieux comme ça oui un
petit peu mieux bon très
bien regarde ces mots en petit ici
est-ce que c'est toujours aussi visible
oui oui si je les rapproche de tes yeux
est-ce que tu les vois toujours aussi
bien et là oui c'est bon et là c'est
toujours aussi clair oui oui ce qui va
se passer c'est que si tu portes ces
lunettes tes yeux vont moins travailler
et tes mux de tête devrai s'en
aller c'est à toi que je donne ça ça a
déjà été réglé et on a besoin de ces ver
avec cette monture avec cette monture ok
il a déjà payé très
bien and Mako est assistant général du
train l'homme toujours prête à rendre
service un jour pour aider les débordé
il est devenu le monsieur lunette du FA
Andr vient des banlieux de Johannesbourg
il est de la génération de ceux qui ne
sont jamais aller à l'école parce qu'ils
étaient noirs aujourd'hui à 44 ans il
sait lire les prescriptions et fabrique
jusqu'à 60 paires de lunettes par
jour j'ai besoin de 10 minutes pour
faire une paire de
lunett et c'est seulement 10 minutes
pour changer la vie d'une
personne
on le voit quand elle repart avec ses
lunettes et qu'elle est tout
heureuse et je suis content d'être celui
qui est derrière tout
ça j'ai l'impression d'être un nouveau
Ron parce que mes yeux voient mieux
une nouvelle vie commence pour Raymond
dont le rêve secret est de devenir
docteur un jour félicitations à vous
tous pelppa vous êtes une équipe
formidable les patients vous sont
reconnaissant nous avons rencontré
aujourd'hui des gens qui étaient
tellement heureux que vous soyez là et
que vous ayez pensé à
eux ce qui m'a le plus touché c'est
quand certains m'ont dit qu'ils
pensaient qu'il n'avait aucune
importance c'est si déprimant et triste
ces personnes qui croient qu'elles ne
sont pas
grand-chose mais la plus belle chose
c'est que c'est vous qui leur avez
redonné de
l'importance dans les quartiers les plus
pauvres d'ington comme dans plus d'un
tiers des foyers du pays il n'y a pas
encore
l'électricité est enfin arrivé mais les
maisons en PARP promises par la
démocratie sud-africaine se font
toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendre les consultations dans le train
sont terminées seul Maine reste à bord
comme souvent elle est la dernière à
finir sa
journée j'espère que ça ira merci
beaucoup je crois que je vais pouvoir
dormir
maintenant en s'engageant à bord du FA
Maine a fait un choix de vie parfois
difficile il faut accepter de travailler
et vivre pendant 9 mois dans un seul et
même endroit le
train si vous êtes claustrophobe vous ne
pourrez jamais vous y
faire tout est petit
ici
au bout d'un moment c'est la 4è fois au
bout d'un moment on veut juste aller
dans sa
chambre et on veut même plus savoir si
elle est grande ou si elle est
petite ma
chambre
alors voici ma chambre petite ça c'est
la
largeur lit est plus petit qu' l simple
n pas aussi large c'est vraiment petit
téléphone m
parents tél meilleure
amieession de passer à côté de quelque
chose qui se passera là-bas à
l'extérieur et moi je reste ici
seulement ici tous mes amis sont en
train de se marier je n'ai même pas de
petitte ami et je me dis oh est-ce que
je suis en train de passer à côté de
quelque chose pourquoi est-ce que je
suis là et puis je me dis je n'ai que 26
ans c'est seulement pour 9
mois après ces 9 mois je pourrais faire
autre chose si j'en ai
envie c'est pas si
[Musique]
terrible je me suis réveillé à 4h3
je me réveille toute seule à 4h30 je
n'ai pas besoin de
réveil il faut que je sois réveillé
juste pour être sûr que tout le monde
soit
réveillé sinon si je ne me lève pas
comment être sûr que l'on commence le
travail à
l'heure il faut que je fasse ce que je
fais tous les
jours bonjour tout le
monde bonjour comment allez-vous ce
matin vous pensez qu'il va y avoir du
monde aujourd'hui ah on espère que oui
je pense qu'il va y avoir du monde parce
qu'il y a deux bus qui doivent
arriver premère arrivée premier
[Musique]
serv circu de cette façon sinon rien ne
va plus s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît la journée bien commencé j'ai déjà
tout organisé j'ai réveillé tout le
monde
et à la plupart des étudiants j'ai fait
le tour du
train dans ce sens et dans l'autre sens
pour voir si tout allait bien vérifier
que toutes les voitures sont bien là
vérifier qui va visiter les écoles et
s'iles ont bien tout le matériel ce
matin Maine part à la rencontre des
écoliers avec elle des interprètes des
étudiantes et une infirmière pour
prévenir la contagion des maladies les
plus fréquentes dans les familles pour
apprendre aux enfants les principes
d'hygiène les plus élémentaires
[Musique]
ande elke dag elke dag og og s en ogend
rond en rond rond en rond r en
[Musique]
r vous ouvrez bien grand la bouche et
vous faites des grands
cercles
cercle sur les dents sur les gencives
sur les dents et sur les
gencives e
écoutez-moi on va regarder ce qui se
passe dans vos
dents et on va voir si on trouve des
petites bestiol
destits
OK
ud au TR d'accord plus de 460 enfants
auront été examinés en une semaine dans
les éc d'ington beaucoup d'entre eux
recevront une lettre à donner à leurs
parents pour qu'ils puissent se faire
soigner dans le train
sy k nie
[Musique]
nie
c'est pas
bien et il se partagent la brosse à
dents chez
eux et ils se transmettent leur microbes
de bouche en
bouche ils n'ont pas assez d'argent pour
acheter une brosse à dent alors la
question c'est j'achète une brosse à
dents ou j'achète à manger et ils
achètent à
[Musique]
manger
[Applaudissements]
ils me font
rire ils
chante je suis mignon je suis mignon je
suis si mignon
oui vous êtes vraiment trop
mignon tu as mal aux
oreilles ok
suivant Mo c'est B
toiie
c'est vraiment à la chaîne mais au moins
on le fait pour une bonne
cause ok qui est la
suivante c'est
[Musique]
toi il faut qu'il tienne le cotontiche
comme cela
ils ne doivent pas le mettre trop
profond dans
l'oreille ils doivent juste la nettoyer
délicatement pas trop à
l'intérieur c'est vraiment terrible l
des visites médicales quand on examine
les oreilles des enfants on découvre des
pierres des morceaux de papier ou de
papier toilette des cafard et d'autres
insectesington comme dans le reste du
pays le chômage dépasse les 30 % et
l'espérance de vie est de 45
ans dans le quartier noir de pataléo la
tuberculose et le sida sont parmi les
premières causes de
mortalité la jeune psychologue du
phéopppa Carell rend visite à christana
un groupe de parole pour une carantaine
de malades du sida qui se réunit toutes
les
semaines je
m'appelleatri Grou
voiciille plus de 5 millions de
Sud-Africains sont contaminés par le
virus chaque jour 1000 personnes en Meur
caré est là pour informer et réconforter
ses malades mais elle ne peut les
soigner les traitement efficace coûte
trop cher et il n'y aurait pas de suivi
médical possible une fois le train
reparti j'aimerais savoir pour mon
bébé j'aimerais savoir ce qu'on pourrait
lui
donner est-ce est que les médicaments
vont pouvoir agir sur la maladie est-ce
que les enfants eux seront guéris quand
ils seront
grands pour ceux qui prendront les
antirétrovirux la progression du virus
sera
ralentie si le virus est déjà là il
restera en revanche il ne se multipliera
pas ce qui veut dire qu'il pourront
vivre plus
longtemps à peine le temps de donner
quelques conseils et le FOPA doit
reprendre Chem en une semaine il aura
soigné environ 1200 patients arraché 700
dents et distribué plus de 400 paires de
lunettes oh ma mère avec ses nouvelles
lunettes elle va pouvoir se trouver un
petit copain
maintenant le train ne reviendra pas
avant 2 ans au moins trop de vill
commeington le
récl
je sais trop bien que les sudafricains
ont besoin de ce train et si je peux
leur apporter ne serait-ce qu'une aide
modeste je me dois de leur donner le
meilleur de moi-même si je peux soutenir
les permanen les étudiants et faire
sentir à ces gens qu'il compte pour
quelqu'un alors je me sens
récompenséing fèle à sonste au 40000
paents qu' accue cha année au nord du
pays vers des régions plus isolées
encore prochaine station
postmbourg ici aussi nombreux sont ceux
qui attendaient ce moment depuis
longtemps et qui ACC cour quand la
nouvelle de l'arrivée du train de
l'espoir se
répand